aoc's I don't know fiance or her husband
I don't know if they're married is white
and Kamala Harris is married to a white
guy or whatever right so well what is
aoc's ethnicity she's uh she's what is
she she's Latina she's a Latina but I
don't know like of what persuasion but
she's she's not white I mean the left
considers Latinos white if they vote
Republican
and they consider black people white if
they Republican too I don't know
that's why I'm confused but so so this
this one was really funny to me when I
saw this wizard the coast revealed that
they will be removing the concept of
half species from The Dungeons and
Dragons player's handbook on the grounds
they are not comfortable including an
inherently racist Concept in the game
what what's racist about mixed race
characters I I wonder is something wrong
well the the the the racial fanaticism
that really bugs me is the decision to
capitalize black and white
oh yeah